Buenos días Valentina ya al consejo
nacional electoral emitió un primer
informe de instalación de mesas
electorales y ha dicho que tanto el 47%
se instalaron a las siete de la mañana y
el 50 por ciento se instalaron a la hora
requerida 30 minutos más tarde ha dicho
que en tres horas del proceso electoral
ya han votado el 10% de El padrón
electoral en este país continúa como tú
puedes ver a mis espaldas llegando
influyendo con normalidad los distintos
electores que se acercan a los recintos
electorales para expresar así la
voluntad de ejercer el voto tal y como
tú lo has dicho la atención se concentra
en la reforma constitucional y esto
también poco a poco va generando algunas
reacciones hemos podido también
conversar con las personas que van
saliendo de los recintos electorales y
en algunos apoyan la reforma
constitucional otro la rechazan de pleno
y De igual forma hay algunos que no
conocen inclusive En qué consiste la
profundidad de en la reforma
constitucional Valentina bueno y cuáles
son los argumentos de la oposición para
asegurar que el referendo que está
impulsando El Ejecutivo puede afectar la
democracia
pero en principio hay que conocer Cuál
es el contexto que se realiza en este
país Ecuador ha sido uno de los países
que ha aumentado los niveles de
violencia en toda latinoamérica del año
2021 2022 en Ecuador se aumentaron las
muertes en un 82% de jugadores inclusive
es el país con mayor número de muertes
violentas en toda la región según
informe también de las Naciones Unidas
Ecuador supera la tasa de muertes
violentas para que tengas
conocimiento la tasa de muertes
violentas en el año 2021 era de 13,7 por
cada 100.000 habitantes Ecuador
sobrepasa esa tasa a 25 casos Pero qué
sucede El Ejecutivo asegura que la
crisis que sucede en este momento en el
país es producto del incremento
narcotráfico y la debilidad de la
policía el incremento de las muertes de
igual forma también hay otras reacciones
que se producen por parte de la
oposición en cada una de las preguntas
en principio por lo menos en la materia
de extradición una de las primeras
preguntas que propone El Ejecutivo
nacional es la a personas que están
inmersas en delitos de narcotráfico la
principal reacción sería y que las
personas aseguran que esto no soluciona
los problemas de inseguridad también no
se va a poder
extraditar a todas las personas porque
no se toman en cuenta otro tipo de
delitos también hay otras reacciones en
cuanto a los servicios ambientales se
rechaza que se quieran mercantilizar con
los servicios ambientales la propiedad
de los espacios ambientales a cambio de
compensaciones económicas son algunas de
las reacciones que se producen a
propósito de El referéndum
constitucional